who estimates that at least 90 percent
of the world's population now has some
level of immunity to sarskov to
due to Prior infection or vaccination
we are much closer to being able to say
that the emergency phase of the pandemic
is over
but we're not there yet
gaps in surveillance testing sequencing
and vaccination are continuing to create
the perfect conditions for a new variant
of consent to emerge that could cause
significant mortality we're pleased to
learn that the the Chinese authorities
are adjusting their their current
strategies
and and really try to calibrate now the
control measures that they need for this
virus again with the lives the
livelihoods and and and and and the
human rights of people in communities
who like all over the world where
everyone has suffered we've all had to
deal with restrictions of movement we've
all had to deal with having our lives
changed and and frankly it's exhausting
it's been exhausting for all of us so
there are natural frustrations there are
natural issues with that and it's really
important that governments listen to
their people when the people are in
campaign and their choices that
Sovereign governments need to make based
on the best benefit to their population
against the cost of of doing that so
with that in mind uh it's uh it's uh we
hope this progresses and we see that
coherent calibrated strategy emerge that
balances the control of the virus with
the lives the livelihoods and well-being
and human rights of the people of China